we've had apples brand new Mac Pro in
our office for just over a month and
it's clear that it's a beast of a
machine in terms of the overall package
that you get great performance
completely silent operation genius
engineering in a very solid and premium
design it's so good that we've realized
that the Mac Pro is complete overkill
for our workflow and that's the $15,000
model nowhere near the fully specked out
$53,000 model so we got to thinking what
if we compared it to the two-month-old
16 inch MacBook Pro to see how much more
performance we're actually getting with
the Mac Pro over the MacBook which is
definitely no slouch there's also one
very good feature the new 16 inch
MacBook Pro gets that you literally
cannot get on the Mac Pro at least not
yet and we'll talk about it in just a
minute before we get into performance
numbers including various benchmarks
like blender video editing and Final Cut
Pro and photo editing and Lightroom
classic I want to first point out the
benefits of buying each of these Macs
let's start off with why somebody would
buy the 16 inch MacBook Pro the biggest
reason is portability unlike the Mac Pro
you can take the MacBook Pro anywhere
open it up and get some work done if the
battery starts running low plug it in
and you're good to go
and just like the Mac Pro you get some
Thunderbolt 3 ports which can be used to
plug in some of the fastest accessories
and drives available as well as external
monitors like the new Pro display XDR
but even without that you're getting a
really great 16 inch display that
features 500 nits of brightness and
excellent color accuracy for photo and
video editing work not only that but the
bezels have finally been slimmed down to
look a lot better than before you also
get a very solid design with the best
trackpad you can get on any laptop as
well as the new magic keyboard that puts
the old butterfly keyboard to shame add
new and improved speakers and
microphones and you get a really solid
portable computer the 16 inch MacBook
Pro is great for basically anyone from a
basic user with some extra cash to spare
to a huge range of entrepreneurs and
small business owners who need this
MacBook Pro to do their work and make
some
now the MacPro on the other hand is a
different beast it's more of a
commercial grade computer that
definitely doesn't give you the best
bang for your buck but instead gives you
top-notch reliability for computing
tasks and performance that you simply
can't get on any other Mac while you do
pay at least $6,000 for the base model
everything from the Ram graphics storage
and even the processor is upgradable in
fact we saved over 2000 dollars by
upgrading the RAM ourselves instead of
buying it from Apple and that's just 192
gigs
instead of the maximum 1.5 terabytes of
RAM if you're interested in upgrading it
yourself check out our do-it-yourself
RAM upgrade guide at the end of this
video the ability to upgrade these
components makes it a much better deal
in fact there are still people using
2010 Mac Pro's because they've been able
to upgrade it over the years and that's
why people are willing to pay so much
more for the Mac Pro you also get the
flexibility of choosing your own display
based on the type of work you need it
for like high-end photo or video editing
the Mac Pro is very useful for
successful small business owners who
want the extra tax write-off in great
performance as well as larger businesses
and Studios who spend more money on
labor than computer hardware so with
that let's get into performance here are
the specs and prices of both of these
Macs so we can see that the Mac Pro gets
an advantage in basically every area
except for the ones Haribhai SSD
starting off with the processor
performance using Geekbench 5 the Mac
Pro's processor is about 76% faster in
terms of raw multi-core performance
which is a pretty decent jump in
performance seeing as it's only got four
more quarts
now running cinnamon chart 20 which is
more realistic test the Mac Pro is
scoring around 66% faster than the
MacBook Pro which can turbo boost up to
a higher 5.0 gigahertz instead of 4.4 on
the Mac Pro on the other hand the Mac
Pro was completely silent during this
test
unlike the MacBook which started
spinning up its fans and as expected the
Mac Pro is the clear winner by far now
moving on to graphics performance with
Geekbench 5s metal test the Mac Pro
totally obliterates the MacBook Pro with
close to three-and-a-half
time's the performance this is the Mac
Pros biggest advantage because you just
can't get this much graphics power on
any other Mac now before we test photo
editing in Lightroom classic let's get
into video editing with Final Cut Pro
the Mac Pro finished the graphics heavy
Bruce X test in half the time six
seconds versus 12 seconds which honestly
still isn't bad before one of the recent
Final Cut Pro updates the sixteen inch
MacBook Pro used to take a full 20
seconds to finish this test in the
15-inch MacBook Pro with the best Vega
20 graphics took 32 seconds so the
recent updates are greatly benefiting
the 16 inch MacBook now testing for case
stabilization the Mac Pro was almost
twice as fast but seven seconds isn't
too bad for a 20 second clip on the
MacBook Pro either moving on to
exporting a five-minute h.264 4k clip
which is the format that most youtubers
use we start to see some different
results
the MacBook Pro only takes around 50
seconds longer than the Mac Pro which is
surprising compared to the rest of the
results we were getting this is because
the MacBook Pros processor has
integrated graphics so it can take
advantage of Intel's quick sync
technology which greatly speeds up
export times for h.264 video the Mac Pro
is relying purely on RAW processing
performance so it's still really
impressive now running the same test but
using an 8-bit h.265 clip or HEV see the
MacBook Pro actually finishes the export
1 second quicker than the Mac Pro this
is definitely a shocker and there's one
very important reason for it the 16 inch
MacBook Pro features AMD's brand new
Navi based seven nanometer graphics
technology which includes new HEV C
Hardware encoding that you can't get on
the mac pro at least not yet
the Mac Pro is soon getting a w50 700x
graphics option which does have the new
Navi technology and we're going to get
our hands on that very soon so subscribe
right now if you don't want to miss out
on that but for now the MacBook Pro
finishes this test one second faster
for that reason now moving on to a
10-bit heb c export the mac pro finishes
over twice as fast as the macbook pro
and that's because even though the Navi
graphics does support 10 bit
a TVC encoding it's actually not enabled
yet we're still waiting on Apple to
update Mac OS to support it and then the
MacBook Pro will actually be quite a bit
faster than the Mac Pro for this test
now onto the last three tests which are
much heavier tasks like exporting a
five-minute 60fps c200 bra clip the
macro Pro takes over twice as long and
interestingly the Mac Pro won't get any
faster because the current Vega encoders
run at a maximum of 60 fps so it
literally can't get faster than 5
minutes even if you get the better
graphics options however the MacBook Pro
is able to play it back at 56 fps so
it's almost perfectly smooth which isn't
too bad of an editing experience if
you're willing to wait longer for the
export now for a 4.5 K red raw export
test the MacBook Pro yet again took over
twice as long to export and finally our
ek red raw to UHD export test actually
didn't take that much longer on the
MacBook Pro but of course it is over two
minutes faster on the Mac Pro and some
people need it to be as fast as possible
to save as much time as possible so with
video editing out of the way let's
finish off with exporting 500 raw photos
with effects in Lightroom classic in
this test the MacBook Pro took around
two and a half times longer which can be
a huge deal for those who edit a ton of
photos all the time now all of these
tests focused on exporting times but in
reality the editing smoothness matters
more and the MacBook Pro can handle most
of these tasks very well because of the
new Final Cut Pro updates and Navi
graphics so if you're ok with waiting
longer for exports the MacBook Pro is
definitely the better choice because
it's obviously much more affordable and
it's also portable unlike the Mac Pro
now if you absolutely need to save the
most amount of time and you're ok with
paying more for it there's no other
option than the Mac Pro overall we're
really impressed with this year's 16
inch MacBook Pro and we'd say that
almost everyone should just buy the
MacBook Pro and most people will
actually be completely fine with the
base $2,400 16 inch model which is
actually 400 dollars off on Amazon right
now and if you're still wondering why
the heck anyone who would pay 15
thousand dollars for a MacPro check out
our review video right over there and
click the circle about to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]